what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today so i was on
twitter and i saw my trending daniel
craig with john krasinski did not click
on it and then i saw paul
heavy spoilers upload a video about
deleted scenes and cameos and such that
had daniel craig in the thumbnail and i
was like
let me just let paul explain it to us
guys leave a like subscribe to spoilers
he's in desperate need right now of more
followers let's get to it
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and though kevin feige
tried to cast a memory spell to make us
forget all the scenes that we know are
gonna be in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness the memory still
remains throughout this video we'll be
going through all the leaks that line up
with the theatrical release the cameos
that the creative team have talked about
and the scenes that didn't make the
final cut we know from interviews with
both sam raimi and writer michael
waldron that there was 40 minutes cut
from the film and that the reshoots
now you might remember last year that we
did a big video discussing the plot
leaks for the film and now that the
movie's released having gone back to
these they were pretty much 90 right
with some major inconsistencies and
added scenes give yourself the credit
variants how they die and the journey is
there it's just different details put in
place for some parts that you can go
check out if you want now just a
disclaimer for this stuff in the build
up to a movie it's actually not
considered by used to report on leaks
that you know to be true which is why a
lot of plot leak videos tend to have
people saying this apparently happens
rumor has it and so on if you say that
things should be taken with a grain of
salt you're normally in the clear which
is why a lot of my videos that turn out
to be true still have this kind of
language in there
if you catch your mind back to the end
of doctor strange then you'll remember
that the post-credits scene had him
going into a quest to kill the wizarding
world worse than fantastic
people mentions how maura has been
trying to kill him when he meets the
illuminati version right but this is
something that we've never seen and it's
definitely not something that he would
really know about as mordo never really
said anything along those lines at their
last meeting nomura was gonna be the
main villain that showed up in the
introduction to the movie and he'd be
used to demonstrate wanda's new ruthless
attitude he would go to attack her and
she'd turn him into mom's spaghetti
beheading him within seconds
[Music]
and it instantly cemented wonder is the
villain from here we then jump to the
gap junction interesting intro
introduced to america chavez and
defender strange okay well that would be
kind of a lot of opening right there
would be like an 80s slasher movie like
right there they're bamboo defenders of
shabbos that's a lot going on but yeah
that was one of the disappointing
factors to me about this film because
mordo's my favorite character i want
more mortgages for mordecai
that's what we're all saying t-shirts i
see it all the time there's a main
hashtag trending right always trending
oh it's more boredom that was the
cliffhanger of the first doctor strange
movie and it did strike me as thought
how they just kind of wrote it off with
like a funny line of like yeah he swore
to kill off all these people and then
haha he hugs him i feel like this movie
really severely underutilized what they
set up for him but if they had that that
would at least acknowledge it'd be a
direct sequel to the post-credit scene
of the first doctor strange movie i
don't know what effect it would have had
but that definitely been a shocker
though to me it's like one of those 80s
slasher moments where it's like oh cool
character from last time oh no they're
dead in the first five minutes great
yeah you know but i think for this
theatrical release the build-up to
wanda's escalating violence is is more
rewarding i think than watching her
right away murder someone seeing the
movie for myself i can definitely see
why they cut this introduction as i much
prefer learning the twist as doctor
strange discovers it i think it would be
pretty clunky to have this open it learn
she's bad jump to the gap junction then
jump to the mcu then have strange go to
wonder to learn what we found out 20
minutes before i still want to see the
scene
out in the open and interestingly both
he and the a38 version are still alive
moro
and perhaps they'll be doing something
with him in the future huge shout out to
josh from denim nerds for pointing that
out and it does leave a lot on the air
for the future of the franchise now tom
cruise's iron man is probably the
biggest rumor that surrounded the movie
before its release fueled by the ultron
bots and the quick cut of captain marvel
many thought that this was in fact him
instead of lashonna lynch i might have
said mephisto was coming here but at
least i can die happy knowing that i
never said lashauna lynch was tom cruise
anyway i'll let that go i've taken the
enough out of that one i'm sorry
this is the last time
hey i just want everyone to know since
everyone's giving themselves credit i
said in our video when we were talking
about possible rumors that i didn't
think tom cruise would actually be in
this one oh damn you're a bold one
you're a rebel you're a maverick g yeah
i went against the grains right and it
paid off big time paid off i wish i was
wrong
we all do now i actually discussed this
in a video and said how i'd heard from
multiple sources that he wasn't going to
be in the film but that i'd also heard
from some that i trusted that he
actually was it was all kind of up in
the air no one knew for definite but
michael waldron has discussed this rumor
with yahoo entertainment initially he
said tom cruise was indeed on the cards
for a cameo but that they couldn't get
him due to scheduling conflicts with the
mission impossible movies those damn
movies
was happening they got haley atwell who
was also starring in the upcoming mi
films i have actually heard there have
been conversations behind the scenes and
that there are plans to have crews
appear in some form as tony stark
further down the line much like john
it's a fan casting that people want and
with waldron admitting that he was
brought up at one point it could
potentially be a possibility in a future
film well also discussions like this
with deadpool and in an interview with
comicbook.com the screenwriter discussed
how they did talk about bringing in the
merc with the mouth however they
realized that due to the tone of the
film that this wasn't the right place to
drop him in and ultimately scrapped him
faster than obadiah's staying knocks his
tie out the way yeah yeah i thought it'd
be in it i thought for sure ryan's lie
yeah and everybody's surrounding right
two lives yeah he thought it was an
andrew garfield thing yeah
too bad yeah multiverse of deadpool many
people of course thought they saw
deadpool on the poster for the movie but
they got you again you punk you damn
chop
who was it then we also had a scene
where we discovered the 616 version of
reed richards was jimmy wu
now on top of this is also supposed to
be an appearance by balder the brave
which i've seen certain elements for in
the illuminati scene we of course saw
that there were six chairs and a space
for professor x balder was originally
supposed to be the seventh member but
this is now
with the empty chair being chalked up to
belonging to supreme strange however
mordo overtook his position and this is
because he wasn't in the illuminati
beforehand which is exactly on titan
along with the rest of the group
with wonder balder was going to be
talked into ending his own life by the
witch but this was apparently taken out
so that the focus for this could be
given to black bolt again it's probably
the better way to do things and there's
already enough illuminati members as it
is so i can see why they removed things
for the final cut this is a similar
situation to captain marvel who was
originally supposed to appear at the end
of age of ultron they even filmed scenes
for this with a stand-in but they were
removed for the final cut now today
there was a report from deadline which
said that daniel craig
however my sources told me about six
months ago that he was actually playing
ball of the brave and they sent some
photos of props across his evidence i
think craig is bolder aka thor's brother
makes way more sense and recently when
stuff was kurt my sources said they
couldn't understand why this was as he's
such a big name oh wasn't daniel craig
originally one of the people quartered
to play thor am i wrong about that
i never heard that i know i feel like we
would have heard that bunch i feel like
that would come up a lot in conversation
who tom hiddleston was yeah i don't know
but you could see him as i think he's
thor's half brother and you could see
him as thor's half brother i was gonna
say either way i'm glad that it is this
case if it does turn out to be that he
is balder because he would make a
perfect like grizzled brother to thor
who's maybe not quite as jovial i don't
know if he could get away with the guy
like what happened with black bolt was
accidental panic stricken mode i don't
know if you can get away with a guy just
killing him so that might be a little
too dark for your marvel pg-13
i feel like that would cross a line
however apparently craig dropping out
was due to a spike in pandemic cases so
i think that's why he was removed and
also replaced olson recently dropped an
interview stating that she'd never even
met john krasinski and i believe that he
was someone propped up in the reshoots
which is why his stuff looks a bit out
of place probably shot on a green screen
last minute in order to replace craig
who could make it to the film that's why
no one reacts to his death
in the upcoming black panther wakanda
forever film in the comics he like
professor x reed and strange were all
members of the illuminati but neymar was
cut for a specific reason bike he
apparently wanted to save his
introduction for the upcoming black
panther sequel and thus they removed him
early on in the scripting process so
that his debut wouldn't be ruined well
let's get rid richard
miss west was gonna be in the illuminati
universe as well played by michael
stuhlberg west paul's from the comics
and in those he was a villain in the mcu
west was the one who operated on
stranger's hands after the crash and he
also appears in the film at the wedding
he definitely blamed strange for robbing
him of the opportunity to say goodbye to
his cat and also his brother he seems to
accept that there was no other way but
mocked strange a bit by sarcastically
saying he was the best surgeon and the
best superhero stulbog's name even
appeared on the poster so it was pretty
clear that he might have had more of a
major role or that they were hiding the
cameos they still borrowed even had a
single credit at the very end but
they're doing everyone's names as if
he's like a big deal
but yeah think in the oath comic that i
read a few months ago he was pretty bad
in that one dude he could team up with
mordo down the line it felt like weird
perfunctory bring back character from
first one so people know this is a part
two and not just another marvel movie
that feature you know i'm getting it
it feels like hey remember this guy
because he'll be important later even
though this scene kind of a random
camera this is
really a part two
to bring back person from prior one so
it's definitively clear waldron stated
that he worked at the illuminati
headquarters in 838 and that he would
mock strange during the lock-up scene
when wonder arrived to grab america nice
ripped apart with the rest of the
illuminati but this death would have
happened off screen waldron said that he
died like samuel l jackson in jurassic
park and not like in deep blue sea
though we said that would have been
amazing now much like how jackson's rey
is killed off screen by a velociraptor
only for a body party show up later on
west was going to be killed by wonder
and as christine in america fled to an
elevator the door would open and his
head would roll out of it pretty gory
and i would
unfortunately it's now on the cutting
room floor along with west's head
and more those to be fair now upon
arriving at comitage we get a whole host
of new characters including ringtra and
sarah these aren't really expanded upon
all that much in the film and if you
don't know what comics they pulled from
you'd probably be like giant minotaur
walking around weird and they're all fun
for them even though they'll probably
get about two minutes of screaming i'll
always take a giant minute
originally and sorrow was actually
teased at being a loving trespass
that would have been more heartbreaking
it could be a bit close but any romantic
feelings between them is completely
skipped over i don't know if it would
have been too much of a distraction to
have it in the movie and that we even
have enough time to really flesh out the
feelings that the pair share it kind of
also changes up the dynamics for the
ending of the movie as wong says that
he's pretty content with the way things
are he's somewhat happy happy hogan
bad example now yeah man that would have
made that death more impactful but kids
are pretty scared during that scene
that's a scary ass moment for kids when
she dies i keep wondering if like the
extended cut would have a zack snyder's
justice league feel where i'm like
oh now i can't watch the original now
the original is bad it's just yeah i
mean i'm too truncated people already
thought first just asleep was bad and i
was they're like that's always fun
to say we should be spoiled by a
situation where it's oh just the
extended cut is just way better yeah
it's already pretty good thing yeah i
like this movie raymie did say that
there would be three of the deleted
scenes included in the home release of
the film really and that he knew what
they were however he wouldn't tell us
i'm guessing that they're still
finalizing what to put out there what
would you like to have seen in the movie
should these scenes have been kept
comment below and let me know
well i feel like the one that would work
best for emotional story context would
be wong's love interest yeah let's just
get 20 minutes of deleted long love
interest scenes yeah sent sex toys
through sling yes that's all right dude
think of all the sex positions you could
do with a sling ring you know you could
have you on one side your partner in the
himalayas or something on the other side
you need to cut yourself but you know
what i mean yeah it'll close
anyway these are the things we get to
think about yeah these are i want them
all give them all give them all sexy
marvel give them all to me and send over
daniel craig's negotiations too send
over all the concept art every idea that
hit the cutting room throw it throw it
in there throw it over there all right
guys paul thanks for being sexy this is
fun this is a really fun one thanks for
putting this together man you you did
good kid
you're gonna be something someday paul
see you see see everyone
[Music]